on va petit à petit aller vers un
système déclaratif c'est à dire qu'on
avait un principe de liberté de culte en
france de liberté de création
d'associations et petit à petit on est
en train de passer d'un régime on
déclarait son culte on déclarait son
association vers un régime
d'autorisation et moi ça me dérange
parce que le régime d'autorisation
suppose un accord de l'administration et
c'est un peu l'esprit de 7,17 loi qui en
plus ne cherchez pas réellement à lutter
contre ce pourquoi elle a été mise en
place ce pourquoi elle a été choisie
c'est-à-dire de s'attaquer à l'islamisme
radical
donc je suis assez inquiet par cette loi
qui à mon sens va entraver la liberté de
ceux qui veulent exercer leur religion
dans le respect des lois de la
république et ne va pas lutter
efficacement contre ceux qui agissent
contre la république
vous savez pour moi c'est la loi des
séparatismes c'est 1905 des musulmans
c'est notre journée
c'est une avancée historique ça nous
inquiète pas à nous les musulmans
français parce que la majorité des
musulmans français pratiquent l'islam
pas l'islamisme la loi de séparatisme à
s'attaque aux l'islamisme nos français
musulmans on demande à la république de
le protéger
d'avoir des arguments d'avoir des lois
pour nous protéger contre les sectes et
des dérives si il n'y a pas d'action sur
le terrain
non je pense que la société civile
religieux ou laïcs aux politiques qui
vont s'engager tous à travailler dans le
sens de protéger les musulmans contre
les 5 contre les mouvances et aussi le
mieux vivre ensemble de se payer
[Musique]
la récupération politique tout est
possible de droite ou de gauche de
toutes les parties mais en même temps le
sujet ça nous ça ne prend autant de
temps au temps mais aussi de d'efforts
parce que on est à 300 victimes 13 qui
sont morts en france je pense que la loi
de séparatisme séduit de la voirie aussi
de faire le nécessaire ça fait il ya une
dizaine une vingtaine d'années contrôlé
la finance contrôler certaines
associations
je trouve que c'est pas normal ça nous
inquiète pas
c'est tout à fait le contraire si dans
leur rôle quand j'ai eu il ya plus de 30
il n'y a pas cette crainte de de faire
l'amalgamme en même temps aussi de
récupérer
je trouve que c'est le nécessaire
aujourd'hui après que le gouvernement ou
le président récupérer pour des fins
politiques de 2022 tout ça tout le monde
voit le récupérer mais dans le bon sens
dans l'intérêt de le commun de la
société française la loi de 1901 elle
est très claire
lorsqu'une association à un objet
illicite elle peut être dissoute
donc le cadre légal il existe déjà donc
en réalité tout ce qu'on voit par
exemple sur sur la création des
associations est complètement inutile
dans ce projet d'oise séparatisme mais
il en est de même pour la liberté
d'enseignement on va venir porter
atteinte à cette liberté
constitutionnelle qui est celle de
pouvoir enseigner en famille
pourtant la loi de 2018 les lois
antérieures permettent de lutter contre
tout enseignement qui est contre la
république
et ça je regrette que malheureusement
une nine vers ce système liberticide
alors que les lois existent parce qu'en
fait on va pas se mentir
messieurs darmanin et dans la
gesticulation et gesticulations verbales
il écrit un livre et arleux beaucoup à
la télé mais il n'est pas dans l'action
et je pense que les musulmans de france
parce que c'est la question de l'islam
radical qui a derrière cette loi les
musulmans de france
il attend du ministre de l'intérieur
qu'il arrête que gesticulation et qu'ils
agissent donc les 7 contre sion qui
dénature la belle religion que peut être
une slam
je ne vois pas de musulmans en france je
ne vois pas de chrétiens en france
je vois que des citoyens qui ont leur
confession qui leur appartient et qui ne
regarde pas l'état si j'ai deux jeux à
poney c'est le premier c'est que la loi
soit appliquée par exemple l'article 35
de la loi de 1905 1905 permet de lutter
contre tous prêcheurs de culte qui
viendrait à vouloir porter atteinte
contre la république
eh bien on n'applique pas cette loi et
si j'ai un vrai veut c'est celui de la
cohésion nationale par l'assimilation
moi je défends l'éducation nationale une
vraie instruction publique où tous les
enfants de france sont dans la même
classe et pour y apprendre ensemble de
la république et je suis pour le service
national et bal à la république elle
elle transcrit elle retransmet ses
valeurs et ses plus belles valeurs et
moi c'est ce que je veux je pense que la
france doit faire nation et dans sa
nation tout le monde est le bienvenu
lorsqu'ils respectent nos principes
fondamentaux on est à deux mille
personnes presque
ils sont partis en syrie en irak pour
faire commettre des viols et des
assassinats
et aussi on est à presque à 10000 fiche
est ce qu'ils sont radicalisées autant
de haine
il y en avait malheureusement le dernier
victime ce pauvre professeur ça moyen le
pâtis maintenant l'autre côté l'harmonie
entre l'islam et la joie cette religion
de paix et d'amour que les 10 partout
dans le monde avec le pouvoir public
aussi il faut que nous nous musulmans on
s'organise entre nous pour voir l'avenir
de nos enfants par la formation des
imams par aussi l'éducation donné de
l'importance de l'éducation dont même
nous donnons de ce corps religieux aussi
parlé de l'interreligieux de leur
rapprochement et les valeurs de la
république le respect ces deux là il
faut qu'ils font ensemble pour l'avenir
et la stabilité l'apaisement